avec une socialisation à outrance on a
plaqué la société on a une nouvelle par
le bas et évidemment ceux qui avaient ce
privilège de se distinguer un petit peu
de par le rééducation haute son privé
maintenant de l'usage du métro
[Musique]
plus de première classe une classe
unique pour le métro ce projet de la
RATP fait beaucoup d'encre depuis
quelques jours on peut même parler de
polémique à ce propos car comme toujours
quand il s'agit de modifier quelque
chose d'ancrer dans les faits depuis
plusieurs décennies il y a les partisans
et il y a les opposants deux choses à
noter dans cette affaire ce projet est
un vieux projet il date de 76 il n'est
donc pas lié à l'arrivée du communiste
claudequin la tête de la régie et puis
l'autre chose c'est que selon les
propres chiffres de la RATP la
suppression de la première classe ne
concernerait directement que 4,5% des
usagers Dominique Bayeux nous explique
pourquoi la RATP envisage de supprimer
cette fameuse première classe
voici le dernier obstacle à la
suppression des premières classes c'est
rames date de 1935 et elle offre
voyageur de seconde classe que
d'inconfortable banquettes en bois mais
l'an prochain c'est vestiges du
Métropolitain seront définitivement
réformés et la régie offrira à tous ses
clients un confort suffisant pour que
tout le monde soit logé à la même
enseigne autrement dit voyage en place
unique autre facteur qui pourrait
justifier la suppression des premières
le RER a permis de décharger les lignes
de métro les plus fréquentées d'autre
part les utilisateurs des premières se
font de plus en plus rares il
représentait 6,5% des voyageurs en 75 il
ne représente aujourd'hui que 4,5%. mais
c'est bien sûr chez ce petit nombre
d'habitants des premières qu'une
éventuelle suppression de la première
classe suscite le plus hostilité pensez
qu'il faut maintenir les premières
places
et ça fait plus de place pour les gens
de seconde quand même les gens
l'essentiel ce sont des personnes âgées
qui ont besoin de s'asseoir d'une part
d'autre part du point de vue économique
la RATP va perdre pas mal de rentrer on
arrive de prendre des premières mais
je pense que
ça doit se faire maintenant vous trouvez
que c'est une mesure égalité qui
nécessite
je pense que c'est mieux
[Musique]
j'espère que ça se conduira même à la
SNCF après
mais l'égalité sociale aurait son revers
la RATP estime que la suppression des
premières lui occasionnerait une perte
de recettes d'au moins 50 millions il
faudrait bien un compenser d'une façon
ou d'une autre suppression ou maintien
la régie pourrait prendre sa décision
avant la fin de l'année la nuit du 4
août pour la RATP en tout cas la fin
d'un privilège institution aussi vieille
que le métro parisien la première classe
va disparaître le président de la RATP
Christian Blanc confirme sa volonté
d'instaurer la classe unique pour un
souci de simplification de la
tarification et non dit-il par idéologie
Claude Crespo
version souterraine de la lutte des
classes la première dans le métro n'a
plus que quelques semaines à vivre cause
de cette disparition non pas une
certaine idéologie mais un souci
d'unification de la tarification déjà
avant 9h et après 17h avec un billet de
seconde on peut avoir accès au premier
réaction des usagers ils sont 9 millions
par an à utiliser les transports en
commun
je pense que effectivement la première
place dans la dans l'environnement
actuel la productrice d'utilité c'est
vrai au niveau de la RATP uniquement
pour mettre tout le monde en premier
20 pour l'expression de la première je
trouve ça regrettable tout de même parce
qu'elle est conditions de voyage qui
varie suivant le l'état de santé de
beaucoup de personnes en ce qui me
concerne je suis grand blessé de guerre
et je dois dire que je suis assez
contente trouver un endroit où je peux
me m'asseoir à peu près sûrement côté
direction on est sûr que la perte
financière n'entraînera pas une hausse
du billet unique
aujourd'hui ces recettes représentent à
peu près 1% des recettes de la régie et
sont en constante des croissances et
s'il fallait faire ce qui est fait pas
décidé une péricquation entre le tarif
première expérience deuxième classe
finalement c'est le pire équation aurait
une incidence de 2 sorties si cette
mesure est entérinée par le Syndicat des
transports parisiens elle devrait
prendre effet avant l'été mais d'ici là
attention tout fraudeur pris sur le fait
Pera une amende de 80 francs une page
d'histoire est tournée on ne poinçonné
déjà plus on supprime la première classe
la nostalgie tu es plus lequel était les
extraits
sur la première classe dans le métro
après 90 ans d'existence cette
particularité toute parisienne va
disparaître le jour de l'augmentation
des tarifs de 5,8% c'est le premier août
d'ailleurs hormis les prix rien de
différencier les premières des deuxième
classes et se privilège tombe dans
l'indifférence quasi générale Savin
Gorny guynevert en un seul geste rageur
une page d'un siècle d'histoire du métro
qui se tourne les Parisiens
il ne descendront jamais dans ce trou à
la fin de 1900 métropolitain avait
conquis Paris et la première classe
aussi moyennant un supplément le
parisien avait droit à une banquette
rembourrée au lieu de l'inconfortable
banc de bois dur et on aimait à voyager
entre gens du même monde qui taille
mettre le prix seulement voilà depuis
1950 le confort et le même dans tout les
wagons et un petit pourcent de voyageurs
seulement encore prêt à payer 7 francs
80 leur ticket au lieu de 5 francs 20
quant aux autres il faut que la première
classe elle servait pas à grand chose
c'était bon ça se ressemblait vraiment
beaucoup et c'était inutile quoi surtout
aux heures d'affluence la première
classe n'était respectée de personnes
donc pourquoi la garder moi je vais
monter souvent en première classe mais
avec un billet de 2 secondes comme tout
le monde d'ailleurs déjà depuis 1982 aux
heures de pointe seulement la RATP
tolérer l'accès aux premières avec un
billet de seconde sans vraiment faire la
chasse aux fraudeur où était en l'air
ils ont l'air content aussi à mon avis
parce que c'était difficile pour les
personnes qui rentraient en première
une intentionnellement de d'avoir une
amende alors que pour eux c'était
un wagon quand même
on est donc fini de se privilège
typiquement français aucun autre métro
du monde n'avait sa première dans les
autobus voilà 50 ans qu'on l'a aboli ça
n'empêche pas la nostalgie les
poinçonneurs les chefs de station les
chefs de train ont tous disparu et ils
ont tous écrit à leur manière l'histoire
de Paris madame monsieur bonsoir la
première classe dans le métro sentait un
peu trop le privilège elle n'était plus
rentable en outre à l'été la cible
favorite des tagueurs trois bonnes
raisons pour la supprimer et la classer
au rayon souvenir en compensation la
RATP bonne fille va faire un geste en
faveur des personnes âgées principales
victimes de cette abolition Christine
Meral guynevert
quelques wagons de première subsistent
encore mais la première classe est bien
morte aujourd'hui 80% des usagers du
métro approuvent cette suppression mais
les autres les femmes enceintes les
handicapés et surtout les personnes
âgées la regrettent certains évoquent
déjà avec nostalgie le temps des
premières classes on avait plus de
facilité d'avoir une place assise dans
les premières que dans les autres
voitures c'était moins chargé moi
j'aimais bien la trouver parce qu'il y
avait moins de monde c'est
tout je prendrai des taxis ça fera
marcher le commerce des taxis
afin d'éviter toutes désaffections la
RATP se mobilise les usagers sont
invités à aider tous ceux qui ont des
difficultés à rester debout de mesures
vont être prises une première mesure
très simple qui consiste à mieux
signaler les places qui sont réservées
aux personnes pour qui la station debout
et pénible il y en a une sur quatre par
voiture et également une campagne
d'information pour bien informer
l'ensemble des voyageurs de l'existence
de ces places la RATP invite donc aussi
vite mais pour quelques défenseurs du
droit des usagers cela ne suffit pas le
désagrément dénoncé les difficultés pour
accéder aux places assises pendant les
heures de pointe mais la suppression de
la première classe n'est pas pour autant
remise en cause nous proposons autre
chose qui est de remplacer la voiture de
première par une voiture métro confort
réserva toutes les personnes que les
difficultés à marcher à rester debout du
côté de la RATP on affirme que cette
solution n'est pas à l'ordre du jour la
ségrégation pourrait être mal perçue par
les premiers concernés ceci n'ont donc
plus qu'à espérer que les jeunes et les
biens portants respecteront leurs droits
ou gros si vous le voulez ce journal
avec un brin de nostalgie pour les de la
classe et du paraître depuis ce matin le
métro parisien a perdu son ticket chic
autrement dit sa première classe il ne
reste que des tickets chocs de seconde
pariez la seule capitale au monde qui
faisait encore de la lutte des classes
dans les voitures du métro ce qui vaut
bien se clin d'oeil attendri de Marcel
Triat les images tournées aujourd'hui
sont de Didier rancœur
pas de doute c'était le bon temps bien
sûr il y avait les odeurs la perfection
n'est pas de ce monde mais du moins pas
de mauvaises rencontres en première on
se retrouvait entre Jean du même monde
et lorsque l'on s'était laissé
surprendre sur la ligne Billancourt
mérite Montreuil par la sortie des
usines Renault dieu merci il y avait des
wagons pour ces gens-là autre temps
autre mœurs dans les stations du 16e
arrondissement juste avant leur
fatidique on pouvait lire sur certains
visages une discrète consternation
c'est une socialisation à outrance on a
plaqué la société on a une nouvelle par
le bas et évidemment ceux qui avaient ce
privilège de se distinguer un petit peu
de par le rééducation haute son privé
maintenant de l'usage du métro ce genre
de pointe en particulier c'est évident
et pourtant tous ces braves gens du
petit peuple parisien croyez-vous qu'il
leur serait venu à l'idée de ce pays ne
serait-ce qu'une seule fois un billet de
première classe jamais de la vie ils
étaient beaucoup plus à leur aise entre
eux chacun à sa place et la petite
marchande du quai aux Fleurs préférait
attendre qu'un jour peut-être un prince
charmant lui ouvre enfin les portes du
paradis des premières classes pourquoi
priver les pauvres de ce genre de rêve
qui faisait tout le charme de leur
misérable existence à quoi bon lutter
pour s'élever sur l'échelle sociale si
la réussite n'est plus récompensée les
cruelles bureaucrates de la RATP n'ont
pourtant pas hésité
le résultat c'est que dorénavant les
fesses de concierge sont traité avec les
mêmes égards que celles qui sont drapées
dans un tailleur Chanel et que les
effluves de patchouli ne laisse plus
aucune chance aux adeptes de diva de
chez houngaro de déployer leur sortilège
bref l'horreur de l'uniformité
démocratique comment s'étonner après
cela que la jeunesse d'aujourd'hui
manque aussi totalement d'idéal
l'objectif de ces messieurs était sans
doute de permettre aux gens du commun
d'accéder eux aussi aux premières
classes et bien c'est réussi tout le
monde se retrouve en seconde bon
résultat dans ces conditions ma décision
est prise je ne remettrai plus jamais
les pieds dans un véhicule où l'on se
soucie aussi peu de respecter les usages
qui ont fait la grandeur de la France
[Musique]